Lo que tenemos aquí son algunas definiciones que
serán útiles para una demostración que vamos a
hacer, que conecta la noción de congruencia
de segmentos de línea con la idea de que los
segmentos tienen la misma longitud. Para empezar
tenemos el concepto de transformaciones rígidas,
de las que hemos hablado en otros videos, pero
sólo como recordatorio, éstas son transformaciones
que preservan la distancia entre puntos.
Por ejemplo, si tengo los puntos A y B, una
transformación rígida podría ser una traslación,
porque después de trasladarlos, observa que la
distancia entre los puntos sigue siendo la misma,
podría ser así; también puede ser una rotación:
digamos que giramos sobre el punto A como centro
de rotación, esto no cambiará la distancia entre
los puntos A y B, incluso podríamos crear la
imagen reflejada, una vez más eso no va a cambiar
la distancia entre A y B. ¿Qué cosa no es una
transformación rígida? Bueno, podemos pensar en
expandir, escalar hacia arriba o hacia abajo, eso
va a cambiar la distancia entre los puntos. Las
transformaciones rígidas son las transformaciones
que preservan la distancia entre puntos. Ahora,
otra idea es la congruencia, y en el contexto de
este video vamos a ver la siguiente definición de
congruencia: dos figuras son congruentes si y sólo
si existe una serie de transformaciones rígidas
que mapeen una figura en la otra. Puedes tener
otras definiciones de congruencia en tu vida,
pero esta es la definición de congruencia con
respecto a transformaciones rígidas que usaremos.
Y vamos a usar estas dos definiciones para
demostrar lo siguiente: decir que dos segmentos
son congruentes es equivalente a decir que tienen
la misma longitud. Déjame mover esto para tener un
poco de espacio. Primero voy a demostrar que si
el segmento AB es congruente con el segmento CD,
entonces la longitud del segmento AB, que sólo
denotaremos como AB sin la línea de arriba,
es igual a la longitud del segmento CD. ¿Cómo
hacemos eso? Bueno, lo primero que debemos notar
es que si AB es congruente con CD, entonces AB
puede ser mapeado en CD con transformaciones
rígidas, eso surge de la definición de
congruencia. Y entonces podríamos decir:
"Debido a que las transformaciones son rígidas,
se conserva la distancia", y eso implicaría que la
distancia entre los puntos va a ser la misma, la
distancia entre los puntos A y B o la longitud del
segmento AB es igual a la longitud del segmento
CD. Eso puede parecer demasiado intuitivo,
pero es de lo que estamos hablando. Ahora,
veamos si podemos demostrarlo de otra manera.
Veamos si podemos demostrar que si la longitud del
segmento AB es igual a la longitud del segmento
CD, entonces el segmento AB es congruente con
el segmento CD. Y voy a dibujarlos justo aquí.
Digamos que tenemos el segmento AB y dibujaré
otro segmento que tiene la misma longitud que
se ve así, llamemos a este CD. Entonces, para
demostrar esto tengo que mostrar que si tengo
dos segmentos con la misma longitud siempre hay un
conjunto de transformaciones rígidas que mapearán
un segmento en el otro, lo que significa,
por definición, que son congruentes. Así que
permítanme construir esas transformaciones.
La primera transformación rígida que podría
hacer es trasladar y subrayaré el nombre de la
transformación, trasladaré el segmento AB de modo
que el punto A esté sobre el punto C, es decir,
que A esté mapeado en C. Podrás ver que siempre
se puede hacer eso. Lo trasladamos y por supuesto
B terminaría así, después de esta traslación A va
a estar aquí y B va a estar justo aquí. Ahora,
el segundo paso que haré es rotar AB sobre A,
de modo que A sea el centro de rotación, lo voy
a rotar para que el punto B quede en el rayo CD.
¿Qué hace esta transformación? Bueno,
como el punto A es el centro de rotación,
A se mantendrá a mapeado en C a partir de nuestra
primera traslación; pero ahora que B rota, B queda
sobre el rayo que comienza en C, pasa por D y
continúa. ¿Y dónde estará B en ese rayo? Bueno,
ya que la distancia entre B y A es la misma que la
distancia entre B y C y A y C son el mismo punto,
ahora que B se encuentra en ese rayo se sitúa
justo encima de D, debido a que AB es igual a CD,
B será mapeado en D. Y así hemos demostrado que
si las longitudes de los segmentos son iguales
siempre hay un conjunto de transformaciones
rígidas que mapearán un segmento en el otro.
Por lo tanto, dado que A y B se han mapeado en
C y D, sabemos que el segmento AB es congruente
con el segmento CD. Y hemos terminado, hemos
demostrado lo que propusimos en ambos sentidos.